foreign
Johnny is kicking us off in Denver
Colorado Johnny welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much for having me
absolutely what's going on with you
well uh to keep it simple I have about
forty thousand dollars in credit card
debt that I'm looking to erase as soon
as possible
um but it's really difficult because I
only make around forty five thousand
dollars after tax and I owe so much
credit card debt and all my credit cards
are over the limit that the interest
alone is almost the exact amount of any
minimum payments I'm able to make on a
monthly basis so just as of right now I
just don't know how I'm ever going to
even make a dent in this because any
payments I do make the interest all but
absorbs it and I make like no progress
what is the range of the interest rates
on these cards
um there are 25 to 29 oh my goodness I'm
so sorry
what are you doing for work
uh I am a appraiser just like a
valuation analyst for commercial real
estate
can you work overtime in that role
it's a salaried position so it's a
full-time gig already I work like maybe
40 to 50 hours a week but um it's
salaried so uh 25 of My overall earnings
are going towards like benefits
Insurance
um 401K savings Roth IRA accounts
um
Etc what other debt do you have other
than the 40 000 other than the 40 000 in
credit card debt that's that's really
just it so no car loans no student loans
um I have thirteen thousand dollars in
student loans but I'm really just hoping
that the vitamin registration would just
kind of wipe that away for me you were
going to be hoping to the Grave my
friend yeah hey I want to go ahead and
give you some breaking news all right
Uncle Joe and no president any party is
going to forgive student loans it's big
business for them they're not going to
do it it's an empty political promise
I'm just here to tell you I want to bash
that so that we can move on to getting
out of this debt you got it yeah all
right so any other debt you want to tell
us about we got 53 total right now okay
uh no that that's it just the the
student loan that I was hoping would
just disappear on its own but uh now
that you're saying no okay then it's 53
total now uh are you a new listener to
the show
yes I just found your guys's YouTube
channel about a week ago no welcome
welcome aboard sir welcome to uh this
weird bunch of crazy so here's here's
what I'm gonna do I'm going to walk you
through uh the baby steps you're in baby
step one right now trying to get a
thousand dollars saved in the bank do
you have a thousand dollars yes okay
great how much left over after the
thousand dollars do you have you have
more than that uh after I take away a
thousand I'd be left with a thousand
okay so you've got a thousand left over
how much are you investing right now
um no more Investments I pulled out all
of my investments to pay off some of my
credit card debt and uh like you pulled
from your retirement
no no I don't really have a retirement
account aside from my 401k and Roth
accounts okay um so you didn't touch
those
no I didn't touch those okay so where
you said you pulled it where did it go
from I pulled it from like my stock
accounts that I'd started when I was in
high school okay a couple thousand but
then when the credit card became too
much I just pretty much pulled it all
out to make payments towards the credit
cards um but then the interest kind of
just like
went way overboard so what are the
minimum payments right now across your
credit cards uh so the minimum payments
across my credit cards I have three
um big ones it's 300 300 500 pretty much
around 1200 uh minimum every month okay
and you're able to make those payments
but the balance keeps growing
yeah I'm able to make those yes so to
clarify I'm able to make the minimum
payments on a monthly basis because I
pulled in around 3 900 monthly
but the interest is so high or again
like around 25 said 29 that the minimum
payment on one card is 300 and then the
interest is
303. have you looked into refinancing
any of that debt to a lower interest
I had thought about looking into it but
I'm kind of discouraged because one of
the options was like a credit transfer
card that might be able to absorb all of
the credit card debt that I have into
like a zero interest card but Research
indicates that I probably need like a
minimum 670 credit score to even qualify
for one and due to the damage over the
last three months because of the fact
that all of these cards are over the
limit anyways I don't have enough of a
high enough credit score okay consider
getting a transfer a credit transfer
card how much time do you have George is
going to keep walking through this but I
just got to ask how much time do you
have or could you make to work extra
doing another job
well I work full-time during the
weekdays I could definitely work on the
weekends if and evenings if you work a
few evenings
uh well it's a nine to six gig um so
pretty much uh if I if I don't sleep
yeah you can do it you can uh at six
o'clock you go uh you go eat yourself a
ham sandwich in the car that you and
that you made and do three hours of uber
hours of work man you have got to get
some income in to pay off these cards
and the good news is you can do that
okay okay
this this is a mountain in front of you
but you're gonna start clawing away at
this thing as you create more margin and
so what you're going to do is get on a
written plan a budget I'm going to gift
you one year of every dollar premium to
help you with this you're gonna list out
your income minus all of your expenses
that should equal zero every dollar has
an assignment
once you do that you're gonna look at
your bank statement and go okay what are
every single one of my expenses and then
you're going to be brutal in cutting
every single thing that doesn't just
help you survive right now and so we're
not eating out we're cutting our
subscriptions we're cutting all the
luxuries we are covering our four walls
which is food utilities shelter
Transportation that's pretty much it
and you're whatever your insurance
premiums are everything else is kind of
a want beyond just putting basic food on
the table right
right so if you do that I want to know
how much of a raise you're going to give
yourself of that 3 900 you're taking
home the goal is to say Hey how do we
get 2 000 of that being thrown at the
credit cards how do we get 2500 of that
thrown at the credit cards and if you
need to go make more income to get it to
4 500 take home then let's go do that
for a season to get rid of this because
we meet people all the time who make
your income who have your level of debt
and they can do this stuff and you can
too the issue you're running into is the
interest rates making it feel
insurmountable but as soon as you start
clawing away at that you get the
balances lower we're going to be able to
cover this and communicate proactively
with these companies and say here's what
I can pay I can't get away from this
right now and some of them may go to
collections but your goal is to try to
clean this up as fast as possible
I'm gonna also gift you Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons start
doing that every dollar budget and
you're gonna feel a sense of Peace a
sense of hope a sense of confidence
about your future you can do this man
call us back when you're debt free and
share your story and hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up and get you those
gifts from us